pendant que la forêt amazonienne brûle
et que des villes parfois des milliers
de kilomètres suffoque dans la fumée le
président brésilien reste en croisade
contre les organisations non
gouvernementales
vous voulez que je blâme qu'il est les
indiens vous voulez que je blâme les
martiens il ya des indications très
clair que ce sont les ong qui ont perdu
la tête pour changer complètement de la
foutaise il a aucune preuve ni rien du
tout pour ce spécialiste du brésil
le président veut juste détourner
l'attention pour continuer sa politique
de la terre brûlée littéralement
derrière wolson arrow est derrière ce
gouvernement il y a le lobby
agro-industriel ce lobby agro industriel
ce sont les planteurs de soya ce sont
les producteurs de viande qui font
évidemment pression pour ces étendre
leur leurs capacités le nombre de feux a
augmenté de 84% par rapport à l'année
dernière et la déforestation en juillet
+ 278% ses nouvelles terres déforester
elles vont servir principalement à la
culture du soya parce qu'avec les
tensions entre les etats-unis et la
chine pékin cherche à s'approvisionner
ailleurs
et le brésil est tout désigné very
concerned l'onu s'alarme car on
s'approche d'un seuil fatidique la forêt
ne pourra bientôt plus se régénérer si
on déboise trop mais la tendance
peut-elle s'inverser on peut imaginer
que si les pressions à la fois à
citoyenne et institutionnels au niveau
du brésil et au niveau international se
sont plus fortes
il devra un peu changé sa politique
comme il l'a fait au début puisqu'il
avait dit d'abord qu'il voulait sortir
de l'accord de paris en imitant trump et
finalement il est revenu en arrière
l'allemagne et la norvège ont déjà coupé
plusieurs dizaines de millions de
dollars dettes financières en attendant
que les chiffres de la déforestation
redevienne positif et ce sera l'un des
sujets au g7 qui s'ouvre à biarritz en
france le président français qualifie
ces feux de crise internationale ici
mathieu prost radio canada montréal